first of all the jacket my men the
jacket is fabulous thank you very much I
love this dress on you - thank you so
much okay so we're walking in a winner
already tonight you just won your first
girl no I feel so there's no like no
pressure at this point I just get to
celebrate my sister and all of our
friends who were nominated and just
enjoy myself now so I know you have this
dream when you guys are saying we're
gonna be an artist but when you really
live in the ding on dream Phineas what
is that I think it's like a constant
reminder to be present and to to sort of
reground yourself and like what you're
doing on a daily basis I think so much
of your life you end up spending
planning you know dreams of yours
aspirations figuring out where you're
gonna hopefully be in a year in two
years in three years and I think when
you really take a moment go like I think
I'm I'm right where I want to be right
now it's just a reminder to really open
your eyes and look around and be there
how would you describe this year
psychedelic I love it thank you five
nominations tonight your sisters
performing everybody that I've asked who
they're looking forward to the first
thing off their lips is Billie Eilish
they're ready to see some magic that's
really wonderful we're really really
excited to perform tonight I think it's
a lifelong dream of both of ours to
perform on the Grammys and we're just
really excited for to see what we have
in store and I mean when you think about
to just even who you guys are up with I
feel like it's the Golden Age of music I
mean there's some really dope music
being made right I think it's the best
time to be a creative in music I mean I
know everything changes at a really fast
pace but there are so many tools that
everyone's disposal and I think people
are allowed to be so themselves and to
not have to you know pay unnecessary
amounts of money to get their work
across you can with it with a microphone
and the computer in front of you can
make any music you want to make so I
think it's quite the best time ever so
far to be a musician now Gail she did
the Grammy special with Gail and they
got in the muscle-car have you been in
the muscle-car and how fast does Billy
actually Drive
I don't want to get Billy pulled over so
I'll say that she always drives within
the legal speed limit at every
opportunity whenever whenever there may
be street lights around always on ten in
two on the wheel you know I'm not gonna
blow over small right now but usually
it's just a hand on noon just just like
ya gotta have a lean in a muscle car
come on you gotta have some sense yeah
that's the rule you can't have that car
and not just be right on noon
[Music]